Okay, so as you know we are going up the OSI model layers and we are at Layer 2, the
data link. Okay, so as you know we are going up the OSI model layers and we
are at Layer 2, the data link layer, and there are some significant protocols that
operate at Layer 2 that we can think of from a security perspective. Now if you
remember back in the old days when the only way to get into a network
remotely was to use dial up lines and modems, the industry had a problem. The
problem was how do we allow TCP IP to run across dial up lines? So the industry
had to come up with a protocol that would allow TCP IP and its protocols to
run across dial up line. As you know dial up lines are analog connections and
so they had to create a protocol that would allow that and what they came up
with is something called slip. Serial line interface protocol is what that
stands for. Now eventually when remote access became really popular they
decided to replace this protocol with something better because as companies
started to offer remote access to everyone and it became a necessity for all
organizations. They decided to replace that older slip protocol with something
that is much better and what they called it is what you see here PPP point to
point protocol. Now by the time they did this they realized that a lot of companies
were offering remote access and what they should do with this protocol because it
was going to be used for remote access is build some authentication protocols
right into this PPP protocol because they realized that this would be used by
people that would be connecting in remotely by using for example VPNs and so they
decided to build three authentication protocols as part of the PPP
authentication protocol itself or remote access protocol itself and they gave
us three instead of one and the reason that there are three is because they all
provide different levels of security as you'll see and this is something that's
important for you to focus on. The first one the first authentication protocol
that they built natively into PPP is called PAP password authentication protocol.
This one is the simplest but it's also the least secure. In fact what this
uses is a plain text reusable static password in order to authenticate the
individual at the other end that's trying to connect remotely. Now if you think
about those three words that I just use plain text reusable static those are not
good security words but that's all that PAP supports and so what it does is it
sends your password across the line in plain text so if there's anybody in
between like there is likely to be they can see your password and here's the
real problem we can never change that password you cannot force a password
change so PAP is not very good and you wonder why did we even have it but it is
supported by a lot of simple network devices and in fact in the early days of
remote access this was really the only option for people and companies to
offer remote access and it's still widely used by many applications. What's better
is the second one it's called CHAP challenge handshake authentication protocol.
What this one does is it addresses some of the problems that EAP does or has and
so when we send the password across the line using CHAP it is encrypted and
you can force people to change passwords every 30 days or every 60 days or
whatever it is that the company decides on and so it's a much more secure
protocol in fact it is very popular out there even today for organizations that
offer remote access through VPNs because ultimately this person sitting
behind that VPN needs to be authenticated and a lot of companies have
standardized on the CHAP protocol as part of for example their radius and
tax and diameter administration systems that companies will implement in
order to host remote access but CHAP much better and in fact it also supports
two factor authentication which has become pre-standard for organizations to
use in order to allow remote access. The best one is actually the third one and
it's called EAP and the reason it's the best is because of the E the E stands for
extensible and so it can be adaptable it can be changed so almost address
anything that an organization might want from a remote access perspective so
that the way that they built EAP is that it's very flexible you can use it in
conjunction with almost anything else and so you see it a lot today in any
service that requires remote access in fact the next slide here gives us an
idea of EAP and how good it is there is one version of it that you would be wise
to understand as we have seen it appear on the exam and that is P EAP and the
P is actually for protected EAP and so what they do with this one is they
protect the EAP traffic across a SSL and TLS tunnel in other words the EAP
traffic that contains your authentication information is actually protected by
using the SSL slash TLS protocol which provides authentication and
encryption and possibly some other things so remember P EAP which stands for
protected EAP simply tunnels the EAP traffic across a SSL slash TLS tunnel but
here's why EAP is so extensible there are many versions of it that the
industry has come up with to really suit any remote access capability that any
organization or service might require so we've got EAP TLS we've got EAP T TLS
and we've got EAP P EAP which we just talked about we've got lightweight EAP as
well and they all provide as you can see here different levels of allowing
remote entities to authenticate through the EAP protocol but do it in such a
way so that it becomes very efficient for the organization that's hosting the
remote access requirements there's even a EAP MD5 which really addresses the
integrity of that traffic as it goes through for example the EAP authentication
information even though we've provided a really good slide here probably the
one that is the most important for you to remember is P EAP that we've talked
about just before now we're still at layer 2 and what we need to understand at
layer 2 are some of the significant devices and protocols that operate at
layer 2 of the OSI model and as far as devices are concerned really two of
them that are significant bridges and switches both operate at layer 2 and
therefore because they operate at layer 2 they are still very efficient but
they are really dumb devices in other words we can't really ask any of these
devices to make any security decisions they just don't have the intelligence to
be able to do that but both bridges and switches are layer 2 devices now don't
overthink these questions because as you know today companies can buy layer
3 switches they can buy layer 4 switches you can even buy layer 7 switches but
unless the exam specifically mentions those words you need to remember that a
switch natively operates at layer 2 and they are both bridges and switches
dumb devices in fact that's why we call them bridges they simply bridge two
things together and that bridge does not care what's going across it it has
no ability to interpret it so these are very fast devices but we cannot use
them to make any sort of security decisions switches have a little more
functionality than bridges do because of the ports that are available at the
back of a switch and so if you connect devices to the ports that are at the
back of the switch it starts giving us the ability to start creating what
are called segments or virtual lands as we will discuss later when we get into
the partitioning and segmentation aspect of network security now these are
some of the other layer 2 protocols that are noteworthy at layer 2 and you'll
know that some of these are layer 2 for sure because they are called L2 L2
TP obviously the L2 stands for layer 2 but PPTP also a layer 2 tunneling
protocol we just described what slip was that older protocol that was used for
remote access that was eventually replaced by the PPP protocol that contains
those authentication protocols that we just talked about PAP, CHAP and EAP also
at this layer is what we call ARP and reverse ARP and those are some significant
protocols that operate at layer 2 what ARP does is it maps IP addresses which
is the logical addressing that's used across networking to specific MAC
addresses which is what makes you unique on any network and so as something
comes in as an IP address the network has to take that and map it to the
correct MAC address and that's what ARP does now when we originate a outgoing
request from the internal network it obviously originates from your MAC
address but that has to be converted to the correct IP address which is what
reverse ARP does but both ARP and reverse ARP are layer 2 protocols that work
basically together now L2F PPTP L2TP or what we call tunneling protocols tunneling
protocols simply take something and encapsulate them within something else and
we'll learn later that this is the precursor for how we create and use VPNs
because VPNs require tunneling first and then encryption so these protocols
that you see here L2F PPTP L2TP are layer 2 tunneling protocols and
because they operate at layer 2 they are still very efficient but they may
lack in functionality as you know the lower down the layers we go the less we
can do but the more efficient we become the higher up you go the more we can
do the more functional we become but the less efficient we become so these are
very efficient tunneling protocols that operate at layer 2 but may be limited
in some of the functionality that they can offer